You have done well to get this far.
Your skills, they are strong,
you are ready.
It is time, time to disable
Force update on page load.
Now the service worker
lifecycle is back to normal,
which is how real users
will experience it.
You see, force update is
great during development.
Say we wanted to change
the theme of the app.
The theme colors are in
public/scss/theme.scss.
These are a set of Sass variables
referenced throughout the rest of
the style sheets.
If I change the primary color to
red then go back to the browser
with force update enabled and
refresh, boom, red toolbar.
But this is because force update
reloads the service worker
from the network on every refresh and
causes it to install even if
the service worker hasn't changed.
Let's say I change the whole theme by
uncommenting this other set of variables
here, which should make the theme green.
But this time,
I'll disable Force update on page load.
Refresh the page, and still red.
No matter how many times I refresh,
still red.
If I Shift+refresh and bypass
the service worker, I see the changes.
But normal refreshing gets me nowhere,
because our cache still
contains the old CSS.
Our cached CSS is updated as
part of the install step.
But that isn't happening,
because there's no new
service worker to install.
We can see from dev tools,
there's no new service worker waiting.
Without force update,
the browser checks for
an update to the service
worker per page load.
But I didn't change the service worker,
I only changed the CSS, so
there's nothing new to install.
We need to work with the service
worker to get it to pick up changes,
because we're developers, right?
We change code all the time.
And we need users to get those
changes as soon as possible with
minimum disruption.
Here's how we work with
the service worker lifecycle.
To get the CSS to update, we need to
make a change to the service worker.
The browser will then treat this
updated worker as a new version.
Because it's new, it'll get its own
install event where it'll fetch
the JavaScript, HTML, and our updated
CSS and put them in a new cache.
It won't put them in a different
cache automatically.
We changed the name of our
cache to make this happen.
We create a new cache because we don't
want to disrupt the cache that's already
there being used by the old service
worker and the pages it controls.
Then, once the old service worker is
released and we're ready to take over,
we delete the old cache so the next page
load gets resources from the new cache,
meaning it gets the latest CSS.
Job done.
We've already covered most of
the parts needed to make this happen.
We know that a change to the service
worker will cause it to spin up a new
instance.
And that change can just be
renaming the cache from v1 to v2.
The bit we haven't covered is how
to get rid of that old cache.
The first piece of the puzzle
is the activate event.
We've already seen the install event,
which fires when the browser sets up
a new service worker for the first time,
whereas the activate event fires when
this service worker becomes active,
when it's ready to control pages and
the previous service worker is gone.
This makes it the perfect time
to get rid of old caches.
Like the install event,
you can use event.waitUntil to
signal the length of the process.
While you're activating,
the browser will queue other service
worker events such as fetch.
So by the time your service
worker receives its first fetch,
you know you have the caches
how you want them.
You can delete caches
using caches.delete,
passing in the name of the cache.
You can also get the names of all
your caches using caches.keys.
Both of these methods return promises.